we are queen and the owner of forte
Tapas Mia Manchester joins us with a
forte favorite so great to see you thank
you great to see you too thanks for
having me on thank you for being here it
smells delicious you have quite the menu
over there so before we get to cooking
just tell people maybe who haven't been
to the restaurant before what they can
experience when they come in so we are
very well known for like that Comfort
like home cooking Cuisine and I brought
a couple other different favorites over
here but today we're going to be making
the palmetti which is a fan favorite
throughout the years well I mentioned
you're the queen of caviar but you're
just the queen of cooking overall so I
say we jump into it and let's see how
it's done and I will follow your lead
perfect yeah so pill many this is a very
traditional Uh Russian dish and you know
some of the neighboring countries they
do their own version and it's uh one of
our dumplings that we have on the menu
and the one that we're going to make
here today is our beef pelmani very
simple ingredients very high quality
ingredients and I think that's what
makes the flavors kind of stand out so
I'll show you here
you can make the dough but we like using
uh this gyoza skin you can find this at
most of the Asian markets in town but
it's really thin and it just boils
really well so you can oh you're gonna
let me I want you to okay okay we're
gonna do this together all right I'm
gonna grab them so you grab like oh it
is very thin and then you take a little
bit of water and you just want to put
the water on the edges over here it's a
dash of water okay
and then here we just have a mixture of
beef a little salt pepper a little bit
of onion and garlic so very very simple
but you take like half a half a
tablespoon okay this looks great okay
a little bit there we go all right a
little more we go we got a pack you want
it you want to wet the edges just a
little bit more okay so when you fold it
together it has like a nice seal to it
right I love this and then if you look
at the shape it's kind of very similar
to like a tortellini yeah that's what I
was thinking that's what I love about
our Cuisine is that every different
culture has their own version of this
like this is sort of dumpling and
following your lead okay and then you
kind of you kind of press in the middle
okay and then you pull it around and
then just pinch pinch the edges okay
this is why that's okay I would imagine
chefs don't have their nails perfect
yeah okay and you just want to pinch the
middle one okay oh oh gosh that's how
you're the professional practice
practice makes perfect but here we have
uh it already boiling so I'll just play
just for you but you see delicious and
all when it boils when it's finished
you'll see them kind of rise to the top
and with that top in the middle sour
cream sour cream makes everything so
much better all right as you're plating
this we have to wrap up here but I I
have to do a final cheers with you
because it's always so great to see you
there our food everything delicious